apple's iphone event just finished and
they finally revealed
their brand new iphone 12 lineup so in
this video i'm gonna go through all of
the new features and benefits
of the pro models specifically
compared to the previous iphone 11 pro
models
to help you decide if you should
actually make the upgrade
first off as you guys probably already
know the iphone 12 pro max model isn't
going to be shipping until
next month while the regular 6.1 inch
pro model
will start shipping next week and what's
interesting is that this year
the larger max model is getting some
exclusive features
that you can't get on the regular model
and we'll get into those in just a
minute but first let's go over all of
the new features and specs
of apple's brand new iphone 12 pro
the biggest change is the new flat edge
design with surgical grade stainless
steel
which looks really nice and premium and
we also get a brand new color
pacific blue the regular pro model
retains the 6.1 inch display
while the pro max goes up to 6.7 inches
and both of them got a bit more tall
compared to the
11 pro models and they actually got
quite a bit thinner
7.4 millimeters compared to 8.1
on the iphone 11 pro models the 12 pro
models are also just slightly heavier
than the 11 pros 1 gram for the regular
pro model
and 2 grams heavier for the pro max and
while the notch stayed
the exact same size it actually looks a
bit
smaller due to the display bezels
becoming a bit
thinner as well as far as the display
quality it's basically staying
exactly the same compared to the iphone
11 pro
so you get the same 1200 nits of peak
brightness around the same 458 to 460
pixels per inch and everything else
the main difference is the new ceramic
shield glass front
which apple says is four times more
resistant to drops
than the iphone 11 lineup as far as
water resistance
the iphone 12 models now get ip68
rated at up to 6 meters for 30 minutes
compared to 4 meters on the 11 pro
models
the iphone 12 lineup of course gets the
brand new a14 bionic chip
built on the all-new 5 nanometer
architecture
with improvements in everything from the
processor and the gpu
to the neural engine and the machine
learning accelerators
of course a huge feature is the new 5g
modems
supporting both sub 6 and millimeter
wave
in cities that support it so it enables
features like 1080p
facetime video calling over 5g instead
of
only on wi-fi like before apple also
added the new smart data mode
which automatically switches to lte to
save battery life
when you don't need 5g speeds now the
even bigger deal for me
is that the regular lte speed is now
twice as fast
going from one gigabit per second to two
gigabits per second
matching up to speeds on samsung
flagship phones
just like last year we get wi-fi 6
bluetooth 5.0 and
the ultra wide u1 chip which the iphone
11
already had as far as the battery life
it should stay
basically the same according to apple's
tech specs
now one of the coolest new features is
the brand new
magsafe system basically the wireless
charging coil inside of every iphone 12
has new magnets built into it so you can
connect
any of apple's new magnetic magsafe
accessories
like the new wallet right onto the back
of the iphone itself
just using magnets there's also the new
cases
which have magnets built in so it simply
snaps on
without holding onto the sides of the
phone making it easier to put on and
take off
and you can place the magnetic wallet on
top of the magnetic
case as well which is really cool but
the best part is the new
magsafe wireless charger which is a very
compact
and slim charger that snaps onto the
back of the phone
and holds on magnetically so you can
still use your phone
while it's wirelessly charging and it
charges at up to 15 watts
compared to seven and a half watts for
regular qi chargers
they also showed off some new magsafe
chargers that are coming soon
like the max save duo the car mount and
the multi-charger dock now the biggest
difference is
in terms of the cameras so let's get
right into it the ultrawide lens is
basically identical between the 12 pro
and the 11 pro models but the wide
camera is getting huge
upgrades including a faster f 1.6
aperture
and a new seven element lens compared to
f 1.8 aperture with a six element lens
on the 11 pro model
and that's gonna improve improve
low-light camera performance
by up to 27 apple also mentioned that
the optical image stabilization
on the wide cameras is getting five
times
faster compared to the iphone 11 lineup
now as far as the telephoto lens is
basically the same on the regular iphone
12 pro model
you get 2x optical zoom and not
4x like a ton of channels misinterpreted
in recent leaks so it's a 4x optical
range
from the ultrawide to the telephoto and
thanks to the new sensors and super fast
a14 chip
we finally get night mode on all of the
cameras
as well as smart hdr3 with scene
detection
and deep fusion on every camera
including
the selfie as well we also get a brand
new image signal processor
for improved noise reduction and better
photos
now here's where it gets very
interesting the iphone 12 pro max
actually gets some exclusive camera
upgrades that the regular pro
doesn't get so let's get right into
those the pro max gets a brand new
wide camera sensor that is 47
larger and the pixels within that sensor
are now a larger 1.7 micrometers
this basically gives the pro max an even
better 87
improved low light performance over the
iphone 11 pro
and on top of that the 12 pro max gets
an exclusive
sensor shift optical image stabilization
feature
so you should get super smooth video and
super sharp photos
and we'll be testing that out very soon
so click that subscribe button below so
you don't miss out
on top of that the 12 pro max gets a
slightly longer
2.5 times optical zoom telephoto lens
with up to 12x digital zoom but the
aperture does get a little bit slower to
f 2.2
to allow for the extra zoom both of the
iphone 12 pro models come with the brand
new lidar scanner
which projects lasers and then detects
how long it takes to get back to the
camera
and then that allows you to use it with
augmented reality apps
like getting a 3d map of your room and
it actually helps the cameras as well
for example the lidar scanner will now
be used
to auto focus in the dark or for
nighttime shots
speeding up the time it takes to take
photos and
improving auto focus performance in the
dark by up to six
times not only that but it improves
depth tracking
for portrait mode photos and it even
finally enables portrait mode
for nighttime photos which the iphone 11
pro
didn't have now moving on to video
recording everything basically stays the
same
except for two brand new formats you can
now record at the same 4k 60 frames per
second as before
but you can now do it in dolby vision
hdr
which is a first time for any camera
ever because it requires the device to
grade the footage
and apple's algorithms are doing it
automatically
in real time as you're recording and
then later this year
apple is coming out with the new apple
pro raw feature
which will record in raw footage format
and automatically apply adjustments
using
machine learning and you can even go
into the photos app and edit the raw
footage
allowing for much more editing
capabilities compared to regular footage
and as a little bonus apple added a
night mode
time lapse feature which can be cool for
capturing stars
with higher quality now finally getting
into the prices
they're basically the same as before 999
dollars for the iphone 12 pro and 10.99
for the 12 pro max
but what's great this year is that they
now come with
double the storage 128 gigs compared to
64 gigs
that came with the iphone 11 pro models
the only downside is that you no longer
get earpods or a charger in the box
so if you don't already have one you're
gonna have to order those separately
so now that i covered all of the new
features let me get into the ones that
actually matter
in terms of upgradeability because in my
personal experience
the iphone 11 pro has been an excellent
phone if you love the flat edge design
then this is the best time to upgrade
because i'm willing to bet that apple is
sticking to this design
for the next few years so if you buy an
iphone 12
it's gonna look modern for years to come
of course you've also got the new a14
bionic chip
which improves performance and enables
all of those cool
new camera features so if you want to
see us test the real world performance
and benchmarks
subscribe right now so you don't miss
out now while apple hasn't revealed the
exact amount of ram
most leaks are pointing to the 12 pro
models getting 6 gigs
compared to 4 gigs on the iphone 11 pro
so this could be a huge deal
for using apps without them closing on
you now you might be saying
i don't need 5g but keep in mind that
the new modems
actually also improve regular 4g speed
as well
and it improves reliability compared to
the iphone 11 pro
so that by itself is great now if you're
someone who's all about the cameras
and that's the biggest priority for you
then i would definitely upgrade because
the 12 pro comes with new camera sensors
which have faster readouts allowing
apple to add those extra features like
the third generation
of smart hdr and everything else and
don't forget that the 12 pro max gets
even more camera features on top of that
and will definitely be testing them
it just sucks that you have to wait
another month before we can finally
start ordering the pro max models
now one feature that was missing is 120
hertz pro motion technology
and that's definitely disappointing
especially if you really wanted that
feature
and if you really do then i'd suggest
holding off because i'm fairly certain
that we're going to get it next year but
in general the iphone 11 pro is already
an
excellent phone and if you're happy with
everything about it
and you feel that the performance the
cellular service the battery life
the cameras and everything else about
the 11 pro
is already good enough for you then
don't upgrade unless you've got
too much cash to care but if you're
really interested in faster lte speeds
5g the new design the new mac save
feature
and camera performance improvements then
i definitely say that it's worth
upgrading even from the 11 pro
especially if your smartphone
is a big priority in your life but
because we don't yet have the iphone 12
pro in our hands
we don't know how good it'll truly be so
if you want to see a full comparison
between the 11 pro
and the 12 pro go ahead and tap the like
button and click the circle above so you
don't miss out
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video